WE ARE UNDER WAY AND SO GLAD YOU
TO IN THE
LINEUP, HE WAS IN CO DUCKS AND
UP BY DOUG ARMSTRONG VERY LATE
AND TRAINING CAMP. THE ST. LOUIS
OWN.
CAPTAIN BOB DRYSDALE AND A NICE
REDIRECT BY TONIGHT
ALL MEN, WHO BOARDS.
PULLS UP THE HASH MARK.
ALL THE WAY BACK TO THE BACK.
OUT..
TARASENKO WITH THE HARD SHOT AN.
FAULK HAS BEEN THERE A LONG
TIME.
IT IN
AND THEN ALL OF A SUDDEN,
INAT ONE.
>> PARAYKO THROWS ACROSS.
BECOME WAY MORE EFFECTIVE.
HE JUST SEES THE ICE SO WELL.
HAS A KNACK
POINTS LAST SEASON.
>> FOURTH LINE AKINS FOURTH LINE
HAS BEEN THE MATCH UP SO
PERRON FEEDS BACK TO THE LINE.
TROY TERRY WORKINGEY
WATCH EVERYTHING JUST A LITIT
FEEDS THE POINT.
HENRIQUE
BOTH FOWLER AND SHATTENKIRK AND
IT IS FOWLER THAT KEEPS IT
ALIVE.
MILANO WITH A NICE LITTLE PLAY
TO FIND SOME TIME AND NOW THEHE.
DUCKS WANT TO
THE DUCKS.
WOULD LOVE TOESSED FOR
ANAHEIM.
GOING TO FORCE A FACE-OFF NOW IN
THE ST. LOUIS OWN AS STEEL
FACE-OFF WIN.
AND IT IS BACK TO HIM.. UP UNDEH
THE STICK OF BRIAN O'R HERE.
UNDER A MINUTE TO GO AS HE
CHASES THE PUCK.
>> DUCKS DID A GREAT